Hank: Good morning, John.
So, by studying the traffic patterns of our
educational channel CrashCourse, I can tell
that students are currently freaking out and
watching 20 episodes of Crash Course Chemistry
back to back to back, and that can only mean
one thing: very soon, a large group of people
will be graduating into the next stage of
their lives.
And for those people, and also other people,
I have made this video.
Hello, future dead person.
I have an uncomfortable truth for you.
You are very likely one of the luckiest and
most powerful people who has ever existed
on this planet.
Now, you almost certainly do not feel powerful,
it's difficult to feel powerful unless you
suddenly have more power than you once had
or have much more power than the people around
you.
So you don't feel the power all the time,
and it's probably good that you don't, 'cause
it might be crippling, but in terms of absolute,
not relative, power, you are basically a god.
You can hold the sum of all human knowledge
in the palm of your hand.
If you've ever taken a hot shower on a cold
day, you have experienced a luxury that the
vast majority of humankind could never even
dream of.
You can write down a thing or make a video
and potentially millions of people will be
affected by it.
That's not normal.
That's lots of power.
So what's all that power for?
Well, I'm not going to lie to you, this is
a complicated time.
I, for example, have absolutely no practical
advice for you.
Your future career is probably going to look
different than any other career that ever
happened ever, so, so you're gonna have to
be thoughtful and careful and maybe even a
little bit cunning, and by the time you reach
retirement age, jobs might not be a thing
anymore, so blehhh.
There is one thing that I can definitely say
about the world as it exists right now.
We are, at this moment, both creating and
solving problems faster than we ever have
before.
So your job, the only thing anyone can ask
of you as a human, is to solve more problems
than you create.
Also take care of yourself and have a good
time, ideally, but you are very powerful,
and you can make your world and yourself better
so do that.
As for how to do that, um, I've been thinking
a lot about Eve Online.
Eve is a massively multiplayer online space
capitalism game that takes place in the fictional
galaxy of New Eden and sprawls across more
than 7,800 different star systems.
And just like in the real world, every player
in Eve decides for themselves what success
is.
But overall, the culture of Eve is one of
theft and distrust and betrayal and greed.
The developers of Eve didn't build this into
the world.
That culture was defined by individual people
taking individual actions.
Now this is interesting to me, because I also
live in a world that was created by the actions
of people--obviously, you know, the creation
of the world also had some stuff to do with
physics.
But our culture is just the collective actions
and decisions of people.
And that culture is, at this point, the single
most important factor in the health and sustainability
of our species.
And we all get to collectively decide what
that culture is.
Now, it might feel like we have no control
over this, that we're at the whims of what
has come before and that we're destined to
end up in a cutthroat world of ever-increasing
inequality, but not if we decide to not live
in that world, not if we choose compassion.
We collectively decide what world we're gonna
live in by being that world.
That's the real power you have.
It's not your job, and it's not your bank
account.
It's a power than every human has, every human
ever has had, and it has nothing to do with
immortality or fame and yet, I think that
it might be the most important thing that
every person does.
And the reason we educate ourselves and improve
ourselves is so that we can be more effective
at making these positive changes, at creating
more solutions than problems.
Because in the end, your actions are what
build our world, so don't take that for granted.
And, John, I'll see you on Tuesday.